[Music]
man i really appreciate you coming out
here get the chance to see our facility
here we got
pool we got ping pong see we even got
like a little golf simulator over here
that's a little golf simulator over here
yeah and then take some pictures yeah
and take them back
back to the cardinals it's crazy because
last year my first year here with the
team was the first year they opened up
this practice facility and it is
unbelievable
uh eat over there food
got massage rooms you guys selling
memberships
[Music]
hey jack what's up man all right man
sorry i can't give you my right hand
in due time into time i really
appreciate you being here how to be here
man so first i just want to start off
with family you know like what was it
like growing up
in your household with all the athletes
competitive extremely competitive
obviously my two brothers both being in
the league now which is sick just for
the unbelievable you just say that like
it's crazy man it's crazy because we
literally used to play in the front yard
obviously me being the oldest i used to
beat up on him a bit probably which i
take credit for turning him into some
athletes but it was uh it was truly
competitive it was wild my parents
started us out in hockey when we were
young and i truly believe that one of
those constant things yeah yeah
one of the reasons we're successful so i
started skating when i was three years
old so when i was three years old i was
trying to balance myself on ice on this
little itty bitty blade
and i think that that taught me you know
some course some core strength some
ability to handle my body in space how
to move around how to balance how to
coordinate yourself and my brothers and
i we all played hockey that was our
number one sport we never knew that
y'all just wanted to hit people like
that that's something so we would go in
the basement we'd have these mini sticks
where we get on our knees and we play
hockey and we bang around and
uh the basement walls took a beating we
broke through some basement walls we had
to pay for some drywall with chores and
things like that but always competitive
always trying to win i didn't take it
easy on them they
wouldn't they'd cry for a second get
back up and get back in the game it was
always competitive i can't imagine
having one sibling you know being a
professional athlete but having all
three
like once you got there did you sort of
know that
they would make it too i knew they would
make it because they the mindset like
and i think that so we come from a small
town in wisconsin we had
two division one football players ever
one of them made it to the nfl all that
did for me was tell me it was possible
so i just had to follow a plan and then
my brothers could follow that plan and
i knew with their drive and how hard
they work and how determined they were
how did they make it we started off in
central michigan yep right
and then
he went to wisconsin
as a walk-on yeah
how
i went to central michigan as a tight
end i was on scholarship i told my
parents school's paid for don't worry
about it right but they ran the spread
offense and i only played like 10 plays
a game i was a starter my rook my
freshman year but i had big dreams i had
big goals i didn't want to play 10 plays
a game and that wasn't getting me to the
nfl so i transferred to wisconsin i
walked on i was like i'm gonna put all
my eggs in this basket and my parents
said they had enough money for one year
of school if i didn't get a scholarship
after one year i'd have to figure it out
on my own
so i knew i had to make it work and
sometimes on your backs against the wall
when you don't give yourself any other
option but success that's the best way
to create success and it worked out yeah
you make that sound real easy
but yeah that's that's unbelievably
tough and then you actually left
wisconsin after your junior year yeah so
how you you go with no scholarship and
then you leave early yeah like what did
that teach you about motivation about
betting on yourself basically that's
exactly what was betting on yourself and
it was if
i put myself in a situation where there
was no option but to succeed because i
literally would not have been able to
stay going to school i literally would
not have been able to advance if i
didn't do that so
i was watching film at 10 11 o'clock at
night with the coaches because i was on
the scout team they weren't going to
watch during the day they had starters
to watch so i was on the scout team and
we were watching film at night i was
showing up early for workouts with the
strength coach i was
on the scout team i was going up against
the number one offensive line in
wisconsin we had like six all-americans
our backup was an all-american by the
time he was a senior like i was going up
against the best guys in the country and
i was like if i can play against these
guys i can play against anybody
and it was
every single day like i'd get my ass
kicked but then i'd get up and i'd kick
somebody else's ass and then once i'd
kicked an all-american's ass i was like
maybe i'm an all-american hang on and
then i'd be like maybe i'm a draft pick
and
you left to go to the nfl after your
junior year right how did that decision
come about i mean i'd be lying to you if
i didn't say that the fact that you get
paid to do the thing you love is wasn't
a part of it too like they told me when
i you submit your forms to see if you're
going to get draft like when you're a
junior you submit the forms and they
said that i might be a late first round
or early second rounder some of my
coaches there were telling me that i
might be a third rounder mm-hmm are you
trying to get you to stay in trying to
get rid of that
yeah so i was like but i'm i'm i know
i'm gonna crush the combine i know that
my film has been good i know i'm going
to interview good so i've been on myself
again i bet on myself went to the
combine had a really good combine end up
getting drafted 11th overall
i knew that i would have an opportunity
to potentially set up my family for
generations to come
and the risks of of
not having that happen i couldn't i
couldn't take those risks
that's that's amazing you want me to
show you the facility real quick yeah
let's check it out this place is
incredible
[Music]
dude this place is insane yeah man so
it's crazy like it's so nice
and you don't get with so much use out
of it up here
everything's big man friendly too it's
got big chairs it's got big houses yeah
everything yeah it's nice
it's designed pretty well too it is nice
features
perfect spot yeah the craziest thing
though about this facility and i still i
need to ask sorry why he did it
there's a hot tub out there man i was
wondering where there's no wall right
there there's a hot tub
there's a real hot tub that faces the
road we got to talk to saurabh oh just
put you in d-book you know you guys out
there eating that's out there
so at one point you know aside from
quarterbacks anything like that he was
the highest earner in the league how did
you deal
not dead or do you deal with
the wealth right like i don't know what
your bank account account looked like in
college but i had 151 dollars before i
got drafted oh man before i declared we
uh we went to a bowl game once in
college and one of my teammates we were
gonna go to a party that night and we
went to the like the foot locker and he
was like you gotta get those jordans for
the party tonight and i was like
those jordans are like 300 so where am i
going to get that and he was like you
got per diem money and i was like yes i
have 300 per diem money you want me to
spend it all on these jordans
he convinced me i bought them i bought
these i had no food i had i had to find
my food for the rest of the week but i
was like i did it so my financials is a
lot different now and it's
you're figuring it out as you go and
you're putting your own spin on it i
i was always going to be conservative of
my money because i want it to last
forever beyond me for generations to
come
but i also try and let myself
understand that you should appreciate
and enjoy what you work so hard to get
so i'm fortunate here i live in a
beautiful house here but i also at the
same time i drive a truck because i
found a way to get a truck for free so
like i i don't drive like a crazy fancy
car but it's
i'm very lucky and unfortunate but i am
conscious always of trying to make sure
that i'm
being smart with it and not getting
crazy and also setting a good example
for my brothers as well do you remember
what the best piece of advice you were
given as far as financially
early on i always try to live off of
just endorsements i know that there's
plenty of
i'm a defensive lineman so there weren't
too many of them early on so i wasn't
leaving that high off it but that is
something that throughout my career i've
always tried and
made sure that i was bringing it enough
off the field where i didn't if i didn't
want to i would never have to touch the
on the field stuff so like what advice
would you give to a young guy coming
into the league now that you've been in
the league a long time the best advice
that i ever give to young guys is
invest in yourself and your body and
your craft right now you you will never
unless you're a absolute genius
brilliant business mind or you have some
unbelievable connections
you will never have an opportunity to
earn as much money for for what we're
about to do right now like imagine think
about some of the contracts that are
going on right now think about
quarterbacks that are making
200 plus million dollars in the nfl you
have an opportunity to set yourself up
with wealth that will last for
generations to come
don't worry about the lifestyle don't
worry about the
everything else on the side worry about
what can make you a make your team great
but also b set yourself up financially
and
it's a very difficult thing because i've
been there too i was young i was a young
guy i know that the lifestyle is
extremely enticing i know that there's
and i'm not saying you got to commit to
it 24 7. like you have to be psychotic
about it but you do kind of got to be
psychotic about it you know it's it's
always the same keep the main thing the
main thing
right and
who you give me flashbacks here man do
you remember what the first thing was
you bought what was your first big
purchase i remember my
my the house i bought in houston closed
on the house took the key drove to the
house
walked through the front door walked
through the back door jumped in the pool
with all my clothes on because i was
like i've never
i didn't ever think i'd like i couldn't
conceptualize my own house like and i
was like this is mine i just jumped in
my own pool i just jumped
that was the coolest thing ever for me
and then being able to buy my mom a car
and being able to buy my parents a house
like they're not feeling like that
there's no feeling like people probably
see me wouldn't know that i used to have
a escalade with 26 inch rims spinning
rims i had a drop down tv in it and all
that stuff man but you get a chance to
live and
you learn no doubt yeah dude that's that
that was like the dream car right
that was the dream for them spree whales
had to have them spinning wheels
can you remember making any investment
mistakes
right because i think you know whenever
you talk to people about money which is
so crazy i always ask uh i do grassroots
basketball right so aau programs
i always pick a kid in the room and i
say what would you do with a million
dollars and it's always the kid who
thinks that they're giving the smart
answer and they'd be like well i'm gonna
invest it right
well you don't always make money when
you invest right have you ever had any
situations where you like
damn wish i wouldn't have did that but
you learn from it right
i haven't had any big
massive
mistakes yet in terms of losses like a
money i mean i'm always going to invest
an amount that if it if it went to zero
immediately right i'd be safe right you
know but the one thing that i am
frustrated by is there's this company
called athletic brewing it's a
non-alcoholic brewing company and i had
a chance to get in very early i'm
talking very early and i sat there and i
was talking about not not an alcoholic
beer and i'm from wisconsin everybody
yeah that's jesus christ you know so i'm
like i got my buddies and i'm bouncing
the idea off them and they're like why
the hell would anybody drink beer with
no alcohol and i was like i was like i
don't know but these numbers look really
good man like people are buying it
um but like i convinced myself not to do
it in the early round and
a year later it was 3-4 x and i got in
the next round but i was i always kicked
myself about not believing in myself
that's definitely happened to me before
and you just sort of got to let it go
and sometimes you look at your financial
advisor and you say it's your
fault he just jumped off and the problem
was i had somebody that was telling me
you got to do it you got to do it and i
shoved them off and now i have to like
look them in the eyes because they went
in on the first one and i got to
apologize but you're right
so for you
over
your years in the in the league you
don't got a ton of awards what do you
think you're the most proud of
it has to be the walter payton man of
the year award because it that's the one
that
hundreds of thousands millions of people
helped me get it wasn't me it's not me i
mean i i was the facilitator i i started
the fundraiser for harvey and i
was the guy who
coordinated it but it was people like
you it was people like the kids from
pennsylvania that had a lemonade stand
that sent in their money for the charity
it was people from
germany and london and people from all
over sending it so it wasn't me
that's the award that feels like the
community helped me get the most the
fact that you raised
over 40 million dollars um how did that
impact you how did that change you when
i started the fundraiser i literally was
trying to raise a hundred thousand
dollars but i was trying i put 100 in my
own and i said i want to raise 100 more
to match it
and the first celebrity the first famous
person the first person to call me was
you with a donation and i'll tell people
that in every interview for the rest of
my life that you set off
the foundation for everybody else
and uh we raised over 40 million dollars
and it was insane people from
all over the country all over the world
were donating and showing their support
and
it was an experience i'll never
experience again in my life and i hope
that we never have to go through things
like that again but
never have i had more hope and humanity
than i had during that time the
communities that we play in are who
support us you know so when i saw all
the work that you was doing i was
inspired i'm forever grateful for
everything that you did there man it was
it was it was a wild time and it was
man you want to talk about hectic that
was the most hectic couple months ever
we were in the middle of training camp
and we were we would i'd have practice
meetings during the day and then at
night we'd be meeting with
uh
charities and politicians and fema and
red cross and we're trying to figure out
exactly how to do it and to make sure
that you're doing it properly man it was
it was a wild time it's something i hope
i never have to go through again but i
also learned so much from it and we we
help so many people because of the
generosity of others and while everyone
remembers that it started for you in
college right you started your jj
foundation when you were in college yeah
and
one of your biggest mottos is dream big
work hard right yeah you believe that's
what it takes to succeed yeah i mean
i've my parents taught me from an early
age to have big dreams they always said
feel free to dream big feel free to
think about whatever you want to be
but you have to be willing to work hard
you have to be willing to make the
sacrifices and have the discipline and
my role model for the charity was myron
roll he was a florida state safety and
he started a charity while he was in
college and i remember watching the
story on espn and they were talking
about him and his story and i was like
man he could how how is he even smart
enough to know how to start a charity
while he's in college so then i started
researching it talking to law school and
they helped me start a charity while i
was in college and
myron to this day is a role model line
now he's a rhodes scholar and a doctor
and he's one of the most brilliant
people out there yeah everything
i'm gonna take you down show you what
the court looked like yes
coolest thing about this is
having the women's team you know because
it's times where
we'll be in the weight room and scholar
digging to come and they're lifting dt
being their lifted you know what i mean
like we i think it was after we played
the bucks we played somebody and we had
an off day and so uh they had just got
tina charles on their team
and i came to the gym just to come see
tina because i knew her and
the
music was on guys from my team were
shooting here girls uh some of the women
were shooting over there and it's just
like one big family that's cool man yeah
that's special
two bad ass teams too right we are
crushing it we might as well scrimmage
through today right
hey super duper nice your wife is a
professional soccer player yeah she's
awesome man she's incredible what do you
think it's gonna take to get female
women professional sports more and more
notoriety i think the more people talk
about it the more people watch it the
more people show up i mean you obviously
do an unbelievable job with showing up
to the wnba my wife and i will sit
around the dinner table at night we'll
talk about the nwsl we'll talk about how
can how can this be bigger is there a
team that we can buy or invest in is
there a way that we can influx
capital into it to make it work is
capital the answer is there a way the
viewership needs to get better by
creating a grounds roots like
if i had the answer i would do it
immediately right but i know the
conversations are the most fun to have
because it's
it's you know it's coming and it's just
a matter of how we continue to to prop
it up and build it up what do you think
is next as far as like investments or
what not like what you're going to
understand but what do you think yeah i
really enjoy investing i think it's
another way to be competitive outside of
the field like you you can look through
decks and you can try and pick them
apart and try and see
where the fakes are and where the real
quality things are and then it's also
things you're passionate about
i have been looking at team ownership to
see if that's something that's a
possibility for me and
not in the sense that i just want to
slap my name on a on a one percent of a
team and be like hey look at me i'm
partying
i want to be involved i want to be
trying to help make those decisions and
use the athletes perspective to give
what i think can benefit the
organization and
um i think it would be really cool if
that space was in the women's space
what year you
eleven going 11 12. this is 17. that's
crazy
17. so what's crazy is
you want to love especially playing for
that long and you know what 12 is real
real long in the nfl so
playing for this long you want to enjoy
if i'm gonna be away from my family yes
i better enjoy it exactly
have you ever thought about
i'm not asking you to retire but do you
ever think about that as far as like
head injuries and trauma and stuff like
that have you ever thought about like
yeah
i definitely i've definitely thought
about retirement
i think i probably thought about it
too early at one point i mean i thought
i started thinking about the possibility
of that when i was 26 you know
just because you
you know you can't play forever and you
start to consider when that day might
come but i also on the flip side of that
every time that i it ever creeps into my
head i'm a competitor man i'm a
competitor and i want to win i want to
leave this game with a damn trophy
and i respect that and there's still
stuff that i feel like i'm capable of
doing and accomplishing and being and
leading and
i don't ever want to look back and say
man
i wish i would have or i wish i could
have and the injuries and the things
that come with the game and i mean i've
dealt with with them
more than i wish i would right but
i know i know the consequence and i know
what the possibility is and i'm willing
to accept that right now to keep going
and once that once that line crosses and
it flips to where i'm not willing to
accept it right that'll be the day but
right now
i'm willing to accept the pain and
everything try to get the glory
i respect the hell out of that too i do
i do and it's uh it's all about you i
want to ask you the same question yeah
if you'll answer it no
i will and it's funny um
i still love to play
like it's like my rookie year like when
i was five years old and i live away
from my family
and
just about every day you know and i wake
up and i'm not there with my wife and my
kids i'm like man is is this really
worth it
right
and i mean i got friends that aren't
playing friends that are retired that i
talk to about it all the time
and
they always tell me you know what it's
gonna be one day when you wake up and
you really can't play you know and if
you still love the game like that then
you you got to play and i think my kids
and my wife i don't think they would
like who i would be
if i was home and i can't walk and i
can't play basketball i still
love it
too much right right and if that does
change like you said that's the other
question though is that when that day
does come you've spent
20 plus years it's going to be jj i
don't care
how many investments i have or anything
like that i'm worried about that day no
question i'm with you very much worried
about that day and uh well when that day
is coming i'm gonna call you you can
call me but we can we're gonna have to
talk about something together exactly
exactly speak speaking of risk uh you
hosted snl yeah you hosted snl how was
that and like is there any parallel to
you know live television and sports it
was cool man it was the best it was a
wild week it was a wild experience but
it was an absolute blast i mean i'm an
athlete i'm a competitor i go out on a
field and people cheer when i make a
play and that's the best feeling
in sport that you can get right um going
onto a stage like that staring out in an
audience and just hoping like hell i can
make him laugh was scary but at the same
time once you do get that laugh it's the
exact same feeling as getting a sack or
scoring a touchdown like there is no
better feeling than that no really
no and it's live and you can't screw up
man and it was uh with so many talented
people around you and kind of it's just
like a team because everybody's
collaborating and everybody's trying to
pull their line off the exact right way
to get that laugh and to get that pop
and
man it was a really cool experience and
i hope i get to do it again because i i
loved it and i realized that like live
performing to me is a blast and i wish
there was a way to work that in because
i really loved it
well you got a job right now that's live
every time you play so you stick with
that for right now man
and so i read that you're a huge fan of
the epl the english premier league yeah
you know
would you want to invest in it or
something at some point ownership it
would be it would be incredible but man
over there was soccer with money with
how it all goes on this is a different
world
chelsea chelsea guy i started in 2011
dda drogba was at chelsea and i started
to get into the premier league and i
used to play with him on ivory coast
fifa to get you every time and so yeah
whatever jd on
i'm a big chelsea fan but man it would
be incredible to invest over there but
it's such with relegate that's what
makes it so exciting is that you can get
relegated like imagine being dropped out
of the nba if you were in the bottom
threes like that oh it's mind-blowing it
is it is which makes you have to be
competitive it's unbelievable you have
to stay competitive and that's what
keeps it so interesting and i don't even
think a model like that would
nobody would let it happen over here but
that's what makes it so exciting over
there that's super dope i think that's
why i was always dope and thinking about
ownership
you know with athletes or whatnot cause
you know what it takes you know what i
mean not just from the performance
standpoint standpoint but you know what
it's like the locker room needs to be
like coaches and everything right yeah
you're gonna be an honor someday
i would love to i would love to
be a governor of one of these teams
that's right that's a goal of mine
man i appreciate you again man you know
[Music]
[Applause]